what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing a future for humanity
the commission has decided to find
google
4.34 billion
is euros man on the moon moment we are
innovating here and we hope that you
like it
[Applause]
welcome to europe calling a series of
podcasts brought to you by the european
commission looking at the politics and
policies of the union today with me
stephen jones and me paul anderson very
good to join you again stephen for our
first podcast of 2022.
thank you paul you too
today we're joined by one of the
european commission's vice presidents
marguerita chinese responsible for
promoting the european way of life whose
wide portfolio includes key border
security asylum and migration issues a
very warm welcome to you mr vice
president
delighted to join you thank you for
having me
let's kick off straight away with
schengen which came into force in 1995
and the proposals launched late last
year to upgrade the rules for today's
altered circumstances what changes is
the commission proposing and why
schengen is the jewel in our crown so we
are proposing a new set of rules
first of all by introducing this new
notion of instrumentalization of
migration flaws which is something that
we have seen recently
in our eastern external border
which is a new
idea a new phenomenon that we have to
deal with
and then we also make sure that the
closure of internal borders would only
be considered as a measure of last
resort and that we keep the internal
frontiers of our union open
whilst at the same time reinforcing the
control at our external borders
i want to ask you about the suggestion
that emmanuel macron has made about a
schengen council what do you make of
this and and whether it's going to add
more complication to what perhaps needs
to be
decomplicated this is an excellent idea
we see this idea of a more political
governance of schengen as an accelerator
as a fertilizer of our work and our
proposals
it will mainly help us to focus in
particular on all schengen related
aspects of our work
borders
front decks
interoperability of our databases and
schengen reforms
do you also see as a good thing mr
macron's encouragement for greater
burden-sharing of the arrangements for
countries first receiving illegal
immigrants absolutely this is the second
priority on which we'll be working
during the french presidency
namely to accelerate the work on our
proposals
to bring about
a cohesive holistic eu framework for
migration and asylum policy and the
french proposals go to the direction of
anticipating uh some of these proposals
in a way that we have groups of member
states starting to work together on
burden sharing
until the final agreement on our part
proposals emerges it may also help us to
accelerate the process towards this big
european agreement that we desperately
need
and under no circumstances i feel that
there is resistance to this idea not
even from eastern european countries
which have proved somewhat reluctant in
the past have they not yes this is true
but uh at the same time the dramatic
events that unfolded at our eastern
external border since july around the
belarus crisis i think helped some of
the member states realize
that solidarity and responsibility
and common border management these are
issues that are emerging
as a common concern as a joint european
concern and all joint european problems
required a joint european solution
do please stay with us mr shinas while
we hear now from ramin samadzai an
afghan migrant now legally settled in
belgium after a perilous trip in trucks
inflatables and on foot through pakistan
iran turkey greece and italy some 13
years ago he's in his mid-20s now and
works as a photographer
here's how he describes the journey to
get to europe it always starts with the
idea of
i have to live here for a better future
and of course you need a smuggler for
that the most dangerous part for me was
from turkey to greece by boat with about
12 people
i saw a wave coming towards us going
higher and higher a huge wave
meters high it basically came under our
boat and there's a moment i never forget
in my life just for a fraction of time
everything was stopped it's like i'm in
the air and the feeling that i'm going
to die
has arrived that's only thing which i
keep from on the journey
how much did you pay rameen for the
smugglers there are very different cases
for example some people just pay from
pakistan to turkey for example 10 000
euros some people can make it with 1 000
euro so it's really depending on who
you're talking with
and how you you get your connection
combating people smuggling is a big task
in europe how do you view it they saved
my life it's because of them
that we get here to to belgium or
generally to europe so it's a completely
opposite
view okay smuggling is something illegal
i understand that but because of that
illegal action today i have a future so
i don't see anything wrong about that
when it comes to the
european policy i would say make it
easier for people to come legally to
europe then they don't have to face all
those things thanks very much indeed
there to ramin samadzai
now let's talk to dr johanna de deus
pereira a senior research fellow
specializing in european security at the
brussels office of the think tank the
royal united services institute
joanna a warm welcome to you looking at
the wider picture in europe give us
first your perspective on how the
security environment has evolved here
what he has seen in terms of european
policy is that it has always been
triggered
by events but now presently we are
facing a totally different uh type of
threat we were all appalled by some
party beheading
with
attacks that do not need major financing
structures so that are perpetrated by
lone wolves uh and also other forms of
radicalization we are no longer talking
about uh only jihadi radicalization we
are already talking about uh right wing
extremism also for a left-wing
terrorist event and a whole new strand
do you see reform of the schengen aqui
as part of the solution i believe it
continues to be the jewel of the crown
of the european union and every attack
to schengen either through terrorism or
through migration
it's um a pillar shaken within the union
but with it it also brings all sorts of
dangers until there is a coordinated and
a solid external border management
i think that schengen can be
a double-edged sword
because if the screening
security mechanisms fail
there is a real threat
within the schengen space how big is the
threat of hybrid warfare to europe we
are no longer
facing a typical war we are in another
dimension where the threats are no
longer only physical but they are
happening in the cybersphere they are
happening in troll farms they are
happening through the manipulation of
social media and these factors have not
yet been completely and totally
reflected in european policy ukraine has
been a recipient as we probably all know
of many such actions and now faces the
threat of invasion do you think europe
has been sufficiently united in its
stand against russia
this situation uh per se is is already
quite evident that there is no
uh unison uh within the union however i
would say that in case uh of invasion uh
of ukraine i think that the european
union would face
the problem um
as as a union dr joanna de deus pereira
many thanks and please do stay with us
let's pick up on what dr de deos pereira
was saying on the question of european
unity in the face of russian
warmongering what's your take on that
commissioner
this is something that is
happening in in europe but it's not
a european problem it is a broader
issue that links to the need for a
systemic
arrangement of of external security in
the world we do not lose focus from the
need
to move towards greater autonomy and
resilience when it comes to security in
europe one of the issues was the notion
that even the fact that we're having to
have this conversation about what's
happening on the edge of europe suggests
that we haven't got it right until now
and that we haven't been able to deliver
that security you were talking about i
mean this is a fundamental failure is it
not of the mechanisms of our foreign and
security policy yes i think it is uh but
at the same time i have been in european
politics now for 30 years
i know well that
these type of solutions do not happen
overnight
we need a process to get to to
moving as a union towards new fields
like security and defense
this will take time but it will happen
picking up on your point on hybrid
warfare how right are european citizens
to feel worried about the increasing
threat of this including cyber attacks
yes this is a new emerging landscape of
threats
europe is targeted let's face it
and i think that europe should overcome
a certain
naivety
around this fact the
we have to be more aggressive we have to
build capacities both to deter but also
to respond to this type of attacks
there is a new ecosystem
both regulatory and tools and
instruments that we are putting together
to to to be able to face up
against the these type of threats
we're going to turn to some extra
thoughts shared by the young afghan
refugee rameen which we'd like to play
to you for your response in addressing
how migrants are treated rameen also has
a point on their wider value to europe
immigrants
are always seen as something let's say
it's an extra cost for our society but
that's not true
opposite way they bring the most
motivation they do the most hard work in
the society so why why not talk more
about that speaking of the country i
know best we have like 50 60 000 people
now with refugee recognized refugee
status and these are people who stay
under the protection of our asylum laws
in the european union and i think we
have a duty to help these people to be
able to give them opportunities when it
comes to education health housing but
they also have a duty to respect
our way of life the model of society we
represent the role of women in the
family in the workplace
the the need for peaceful coexistence
and religious tolerance so this
integration it's it's a two-way street
and what about mr vice president ramin's
earlier statement that people smugglers
have in fact served him and his family
well
ramin is
sharing with us his his own experience
but i think when it comes to policy
response from the european union
for us one thing is clear
we need
to break the business model of the
smugglers
the smugglers are merchants of human
suffering and misery
they try to exploit all the difficulties
we're having so basically smugglers
think they can go through our cracks and
they can sort of exploit our weakness so
the moment
that we get to this agreement on our
pact proposals the whole smuggling model
will stop or significantly reduce
many thanks at this stage of the podcast
we'd like to fire off some lighter more
personal questions to get to know the
man behind the role myself and paul
following quickly one after the other
that's that's fun that's promising
so let's kick off what book are you
reading at the moment i just finished uh
a book by anne applebaum called the
twilight of democracy
and i just started
another one by mark mazzawa on the greek
revolution in the making of europe both
very exciting very interesting
what do you plan to do after your
mandate here ends
well
let me
share with you uh
my personal thoughts about the future
actually i would like very much to
to go where i started
which is
the college of europe in british it
would be delighted if i would have an
opportunity to go back to the college of
europe
and and keep
talking engaging with young europeans as
i did uh
35 years ago
both my previous colleagues frederica
mogherini and hermann van rompe made it
why not me
what's your favorite dish to cook for
your family ah that's easy during the
pandemic i rediscovered that i had
certain culinary abilities and i
actually
now consider myself an expert on on
artichokes so i have
a recipe for artichokes with a lemon
sauce which is a
greek recipe with with a brussels twist
if i may say
if you didn't have your current position
in the commission in the college of
commissioners what other job would you
covet there
actually mine
this is my dream job
[Music]
by the time we air this podcast we'll be
six weeks on from the beginning of 2022.
what was your new year's resolution and
have you stuck to it so far it was
to
eat better
and have proper lunches which i never
had
and no i haven't stuck to it yet i i
didn't manage
[Music]
that's an idea
now
three of your favorite albums what does
vice president sheenas like to listen to
in his downtime
well that's generational i
my favorite album was
dire straits the debut album of 1978
and police
synchronicity i'm i'm
that's my generation i cannot help it
what would be your ideal job in another
life
i think that i would enjoy
teaching
or doing your job in journalism i
i never did actually i never taught and
i never worked as a journalist but i
have met many many academics and many
journalists in my life and i think that
i would enjoy that
if i had another life i would enjoy
either of these professions
what is your favorite film and who's
your favorite actor or actress
well uh
actress
marion cotija
actor
anthony hopkins and uh daniel day lewis
and film film i think i was very much
impressed by schindler's list and uh now
that i
i also have responsibilities and work on
the fight against anti-semitism
i uh this is a film probably the only
uh white spot in in the dark pages of uh
holocaust and the dark years of the
shoha so yes this is a film my treasure
[Music]
great thank you very much mr vice
president and we'll let you get back to
your job now and perhaps a lunch that
you may have delayed for us
thank you thank you for having me i
enjoyed it
well that's it from us for now we'll be
back soon with another edition of europe
calling tackling another issue at the
heart of european life with those trying
to shape it
you can tune into previous editions on
the dg comm website and all good podcast
platforms
but for now from me and stephen goodbye
what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing a future for humanity
the commission has decided to find
google 4.34
billion euros
this is europe's man on the moon moment
we are innovating here and we hope that
you like it
[Applause]